le fait du jour de ce 22 janvier
consacré donc à renault et à cette
réunion qui vient de se tenir entre
direction et représentants syndicaux la
7ème réunion dans le cadre des accords
de compétitivité elle intervient après l
annonce de la suppression de plus de
7500 postes par le jeu principalement
des départs à la retraite ou der par des
départs volontaires
ce sera pour la france d'ici 2016
bonsoir bernard guillard et vous êtes
syndicaliste sud au technocentre renault
à guyancourt le constructeur qui
envisage on l'a appris aujourd'hui des
gels de salaires en 2013 une
augmentation de 0,5 pour cent en 2014
0,75 pour cent en 2015
quelle est votre réaction sur cette
annonce notre réaction c'est un quasi
blocage des salaires puisqu'on n'y aura
pas de râpage d'inflation y aura aucune
possibilité d'augmentation individuelle
pour les salariés et finalement ça ne
fait que porter atteinte au moral des
salariés qui sont beaucoup investis dans
l'entreprise ces dernières années et qui
depuis 2008 n'ont pratiquement aucun
remerciement puisque les salaires ont
très peu augmenté en fait depuis lors de
la réunion de ce matin il a aussi été
question que 80 mille véhicules par an
en provenance des partenaires tels
nissan par exemple soient produits en
france cela permettrait de soutenir
l'activité du groupe selon le
constructeur renault
vous partagez cet avis ce sera un plus
pour maintenir la production où ce sera
qu'un artifice c'est un artifice pour
maintenir la production ça peut
permettre de manière des sites de
production artificiellement pendant un
certain temps mais on a absolument
aucune garantie sur la durée du maintien
de ses sites puisque la négociation
actuelle la direction ne s'engage pas au
delà de 2016 pour les sites
par contre elle demande aux salariés de
faire énormément d'efforts d'accepter
une forte mobilité s'ils sont pas
d'accord ils sont licenciés
c'est très simple et finalement il n'y a
absolument pas un donnant-donnant ce
sera plutôt un donnant perdant où on a
très peu de chance finalement d'être sûr
de s'y retrouver dos pour des sites
comme flins en particulier il n'y a
absolument aucune garantie puisque vous
parlez des différents sites notamment
ceux qui te flandres située dans le
département des yvelines je voudrais
vous montrer ces deux tweets qui ont été
postées cet après-midi par la
communication du groupe renault sont
détruites officielle sur le premier on
lit si accor pas de fermeture pas de
plan
de licenciement ce qui sous-entend aussi
que s'il n'y a pas d'accord il y aura
des fermetures et un plan de
licenciements et pour autant un deuxième
tweet qui est arrivé une vingtaine de
minutes après ou renault dément vouloir
fermer deux usines s'il n'y avait pas
d'accord ça semble finalement assez
confluent confus vous aujourd'hui vous
craignez véritablement des fermetures de
sites et pourquoi pas celui de flins qui
aurait été cité cet après midi c'est ce
qu'ont rapporté certains des syndicats
qui étaient présents aux réunions avec
la direction il faut déjà rappeler qu'il
ya quelques années on nous a promis à
flinde de développer une usine pour des
batteries finalement c'est tombé à l'eau
ça ne se fera pas donc les promesses
mensongères on est un petit peu habitué
donc il faut être extrêmement prudent
par rapport aux promesses notre
employeur il ya une réalité qui se cache
derrière le plan et on le voit très
nettement c'est qu'on ne sait pas quel
est l'avenir au delà de 2016 et
probablement c'est un plan à long terme
qui consiste à mondialiser la production
dans lequel la partie française va être
réduite en peau de chagrin
nissan ou d'autres partenaires pourront
faire du haut de gamme au moyen de gamme
comme par exemple mercedes et les moyens
de renault n'en particulier du
technocentre seront utilisés pour
développer les véhicules type low cost
telles la dacia qui n'est pas uniquement
commercialisée en europe qui est soit
planète
on parle de l'avenir de ce bourg de la
mère du constructeur ont parlé notamment
de flan ça concerne le département des
yvelines forcément si vous me suivez sur
sûreté les fils on peut évoquer le
technocentre qu'on aperçoit sur ces
images aussi est là on travaille plus
sur la recherche sur le développement
vous aussi vous êtes menacés par des
éventuelles suppressions
oui on est menacée dans la mesure où une
grande majorité des départs 10
volontaires vont concerner le général il
faut savoir que le générique qui
représentait pratiquement un bus avec
des prestataires plus de 15000 personnes
il ya quelques années va tomber à terme
a chip de 8600 personnes en france dont
ce qui signifie que dans le cas de ces
restructurations il va y avoir une
augmentation de la charge de travail
pour les personnels restant va y avoir
des départs forcés
il y avait beaucoup de personnes qui va
démobiliser qui vont partir en fait et
d'autres personnes vont être mutés sur
d'autres sites plus ou moins contraints
et donc c'est quand même situation assez
catastrophique toi technocentre caler
votre demande aujourd'hui en tant que
syndicaliste auprès de la direction de
renault notre demande aujourd'hui c'est
de s'assurer qu'on se donne vraiment les
moyens de pro
en france alors quand on sait que les
clients ils attendent plusieurs mois
avant d'avoir une voiture alors que les
usines sont bloquées à flux tendu et ne
répond pas à la demande
donc la première chose ça serait quand
même que les usines permettent d'offrir
la demande aux clients
la deuxième chose qu'il faut prendre en
compte c'est qu'on a une direction qui
pendant des années a refusé tout
développement et où tout recherché toute
innovation et finalement a tout fait
pour bloquer le développement de la
société d'oka nous redonne les moyens
pour se développer
nous allons nous rendre technocentre
renault à guyancourt à présent ce matin
anthony rech et patrick jacques de
dixmude de rencontrer un autre
représentant syndical
une autre délégation celle de la cgt la
grève vient d'être votée dans quasiment
tous les sites de renault au
technocentre de guyancourt
un débrayage d'une heure sera effectué
ce mercredi matin 10 heures après l
annonce du plan de compétitivité par la
direction le 15 janvier dernier qui
prévoit 8260 suppressions de postes les
réunions de concertation avec les
syndicats s'intensifie des rendez vous
hebdomadaire pour lesquelles les
représentants syndicaux n'obtiennent
selon eux eu que peu d'éléments sur la
restructuration de l'entreprise
en tout cas la cgt pose des questions
qui aujourd'hui sont sans réponse
entre autres sur l'organisation du
travail sur les conditions de travail
des salariés qui vont rester sur tout un
tas de dispositifs qu'ils ont proposé
les syndicats réclament une
revalorisation des salaires à hauteur de
l'inflation
ils s'inquiètent aussi du manque
d'engagement de la direction delà de
2016 sur les non fermetures de sites par
exemple date d'échéance du plan de
restructuration
bernard guy rey pour le syndicat sud
toujours au technocentre renault à
guyancourt vous appeler aussi un
débrayage demain matin demain mercredi
tout à fait nous appelons à ce débrayage
conjointement avec la société et y
vous pensez que le mouvement peut faire
renforcer cette durcir aussi sur ce site
du technocentre bas nous souhaitons
qu'ils se durcissent parce que nous nous
sommes convaincus que c'est l'avenir des
salariés qui en jeu et s'il ne se durcit
pas malheureusement à long terme nous ce
qu'on perde on du côté de la cfdt
également pour mentionner sept autres
syndicats on accuse carlos ghosn
directement le pdg de l'entreprise de
favoriser par exemple nissan les
constructeurs allié à renault
aujourd'hui est ce que vous partagez cet
avis et au delà de ça est ce que vous
aussi vous souhaitez voir un changement
de direction
parce que c'est le cas de la cfdt oui on
souhaite un changement de direction vu
que depuis que carlos ghosn est de
pouvoir les choses ne font que
s'aggraver pour renault donc nous
souhaitons effectivement un changement
de direction mais ce qui compte surtout
c'est d'avoir des responsables
d'entreprises qui ont une politique
industrielle et non pas une politique
financière
or aujourd'hui c'est une logique
financière qu'ils se moquent totalement
des salariés et qui se moque totalement
de l'industrie automobile en fait que
carlos ghosn vente des voitures ou des
vignes pour lui c'est la même chose vos
collègues de psa qui ne travaille
également dans l'automobile sur le site
d'aulnay sont en grève à l'usiné
d'aulnay vous avez une pensée pour eux
un mot alors adressé aussi parce que ce
mouvement ces difficultés dans
l'automobile elle concerne tout le monde
oui il ya une crainte scribe et crise
effectivement d'industrie automobile en
france et en europe mais
il faut aussi réfléchir à coquelles sera
l'avenir de l'automobile de demain or
nos sociétés ne se donne pas les moyens
de cette réflexion et une solidarité
entre ces différents salariés des deux
groupes qui sont pourtant opposés dans
les ventes en tout cas on a une lutte
commune donc effectivement une
solidarité
je veux dire nous avons quand même des
actions communes oui merci bernard
guéret du syndicat sud au technocentre
renault à guyancourt d'être venu sur ce
plateau
nous continuons à dérouler l'actualité
du jour sur tv fils dans le 7-8 avec à
présent un point sur l'hébergement
d'urgence